[موسيقى]
السلام
عليكم الحق وقفتي في المكان ادم حملتني
مسؤوليه كبيره لكن الرساله اللي نبي
نوصلها تستحق ان تستمع وتنقل الى كل متشمع
بالك تغير وجهه نظر الحياه انا مالك عشت
طفوله طبيعيه وبصحه جيده رياضي ومن
هواياتي كره القدم والسباحه وبعض الرياضات
الاخرى يعني شغفي هو الرياضه هذا مش معناه
اني مش مهتم بتكوين شخصيتي العلميه والم
بالعكس ماشي بشكل تمام في دراستي حياتي
وعلاقاتي الاجتماعيه نشوف فيها متازه بشكل
كبير قبل ثوره ليبيا سنه 2011 كنت نحب
نشارك في الرياضات والمسابقات والدوريات
وما الى ذلك بس كانت عندي مشكله بما ان
الوضع الطبيعي لاي انسان مادام عنده اراده
كان يقدر يفوز في البطوت فما كانش عندي
دافع كبير المهم كان عندي اني نشارك
ونمارس هوا بعد الثوره رويتي تغير اصبحت
شغوف المشاركه مهتم بتحقيق الانتصارات
والحصول على ميداليات وفعلا تحصلت على
الترتيب الاول
سباحه مساحه 200 متر سباحه حره تحصلت على
الترتيب الاول في كره ال طائره الشاطئيه
وميداليات في الالعاب
القوه تو كلكم تتساءلوا وين الرساله وين
التحدي التحدي في التغيير اللي صار فتره
الثوره الوسيله لتحقيق البطولات
والانجازات كانت
مختلفه اقوللكم شنو
التحدي اد وال
التحدي
فخط رجلي في الثوره اللي كانت اهم عنصر في
ممارسه
رياضتي شاركت في الحرب لاني كان لازم من
وجهه نظري لازم من التغيير فالموضوع كان
له ابعاد سياسيه فحكايه كانت
متداخله بس حبي البلاد هو اللي دفعني فقط
لمشاركه من اجل التغيير الايجابي بغد نظرا
كانت النتيجه سلبيه ام ايجابيه بس كان
لازم التضحيه وهذا اللي صار ونتيجه
التضحيه تغيرت وجهه نظري للحياه بصوره
عامه وللوطن بصوره خاصه فالانسان ما يشعر
بالقيمه الحقيقيه لاي شيء الا لما يضحي
بشيء غالي من اجله وفعلا زاد حبي وولائي
وانتمائي للبلاد بشكل كبير رغم ان الظروف
كانت محبطه نرجع بكم شوي
القصه كانت الاصابه يوم
11/7
2011 ذهبت للعلاج في تونس مع مجموعه جرحه
فبعد فتره ك من طلق العلاج سمعنا ان عمليه
تحرير طرابلس قريب تبدا فرجعت قبل استكمال
علاجي بش نشارك في عمليه التحرير وفعلا
شاركت وان برجل وحده وكان كل همي ان الحرب
تنتهي وبلا
تستقر بعد التحرير بعد اعلان التحرير
واستقرار النسبي ع تواجد محصل العلاج فبعد
فتره طويله ه حصلت علاج في
بريطانيا وقيت قدامي مشاكل واجب عشان نركب
طرف صناعي جيد وبعد ما كملت علاجي كان
عندي فرصه اني نقعد في بريطانيا ما نروحش
بس بالعكس كنت متشوق للرجوع كنت نبي نساهم
اي طريقه في بناء الدوله فرجعت ليبيا
ورجعت لدراستي في كليه الهندسه وكانت
الكليه واحده من المشاكل لقيتها قدامي
كانت الكليه من ثلاث ادوار طبعا زيها زي
اي مبنى في ليبيا مش متوفر فيها لا دروج
متحرك ولا مصعد
فكانت عندي مشكله كنت نركب مرات في اليوم
مرتين للدور الثالث مش نحضر المحاضره لان
اغلب المحاضرات كانت في الدور
الثالث ولقيت مشكله ثانيه كانت وجهه نظر
الناس ه كان ان شخص دوي احتياجات خاصه هيك
يشوفوه انه ما عند ما يقدم رغم هذه الظروف
حبيت نعيش حياه طبيعيه وجهت كل التحديات
مش نرجع حيات
الرياضيه فرديت نارس في هوايتي كره
القدم
وقعدت رديت نتدرب في صاله كمال اسام وبديت
نسعى في لعبه
السباحه فتواصلت مع البار الاولمبيه
الليبيه وطلب مني اني نمشي لطرابلس فمشيت
وسبحت قدام مدرب وقال لي ممتاز بحاجه بعد
التدريب تكون ممتاز جدا فبعد فتره اكي
اتصل بي وقال لي في بطوله عربيه في مصر
وبوك تشارك فيها وانا طبعا قاعد من غير
التدريب ولا عنايه ولا اي اهتمام ف ومش
متوفر حواد سباحه في البلاد مش ندرب فيها
وكان كانت في شتيه شهر
ثلاثه فبدات حسابت قلت ما في الا تو نمشي
ندر في البحر فقعد نمشي ندر في البحر فيجو
بارد وكانت الميه
تصقع ف مره خاش المصيب كنت اض المصف تمشي
بروحي موقف اللي ديما يصيرلي لما نطلع
بالجلات يعني نطلع من غير طرف صناعي انا
خايت رحله مدرسيه كانوا طالبات ثانويه
فاول ما شافوني خافوا وقعدوا يعيط
فالموضوع ده كنت مش تعود عليه قبل لكن تو
با تعودت عليه وخذت عليه فقعدت ندرب ونمشي
في الجول مصقع والميه كانت مصقعه بعد فتره
اتصل ب مدرب وقاللي تم الغاء المشاركه
عشان ما حصلنا عليه
تاشيره طبعا يعني مع كنت نحر في مي لكن ما
وقفتش عندها وقعدت نخدم روحي شاركت بعدها
في بطوله السلام الصيف الماضي وكانت مسافه
السباق 1500 متر وسباحه مع مع سباحين مش
من فئه دوري الاحتياجات
الخاصه كانت مسافه طويله وتبي تدريب وانا
قاعد من غير تدريب فشاركت وكان كل هدفي ان
نقطع المسافه 1500 متر فقطعت المسافه 1500
متر وتحصلت على الترتيب السابع في السبا
قده وانا طالع كنت مش قادر نمشي حتى من كت
التعب مش قادر نمشي بالجلال فجا احد
المشرفين على البطوله وقال لي ما عليك
ملام طبعا حسبت هيك شو يقصد ب
ما عليك ملام فحبيت نثبت ان زيكم ما فيش
فرق بيني وبينكم وهذا خلاني دافع اني نزيد
نخش ونشارك المسابقات فعلا شاركت في
مهرجان جنات الالعاب الشاطئيه ولعبت في
سباط سباحه 200 متر وتحصلت على الترتيب
الاول في فئه د الاجات
الخاصه ولعبت مع فريق جمعيه ابطال ليبيا
الفاقدين الاطراف في كره الطائره سئيه
جلوس ولعبنا ضد فرق لهم خبره كبيره في كره
الطائره جلوس ولاعبين في المنتخب الليبي
وتحصل البطوله بعد فوز في جميع
المباريات وتوا ساعي انو من معارف جمعيه
ابطال ليبيا فاقدين الاطراف على انشاء
ناضي رياضي مختص بفئه دولي احتياجات
الخاصه لان مدينه مصراته ما فيهاش نادي
مختص بهذه الفئه ومازال عندي اسراء وطموح
وتح حدي اني نمشي نشارك في الالعاب البار
اولمبيه العالميه ونحقق الالقاب ونحصل على
الميداليات ونرفع علم بلادي فوق في
المحافل
الدوليه نختم كلامي بالاراده هي اللي تصنع
التغيير نحن من الاثر مهما كانت الظروف
صعبه يمكننا صناع التغيير اجدادنا غيروا
واقعهم مرير وصنعوا لنا الحريه والاستقلال
ونحن يجب ان نقتفي اثارهم بحب هذا الاثر
بحب هذا التراب لكي نصنع اثر الاجيال
القادمه تحقق به السعاده والسلامه وتحقق
به العيش الكريم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[تصفيق]
وبركاته